-Seth, your new movie,
"An American Pickle,"
is about a 1920s immigrant
who gets himself pickled
and wakes up in the present day.
With that in mind, I thought
we could play something
we're calling
The Pickle Juice Challenge.
-♪ Take a shot of the pickle ♪
♪ Take a shot of the pickle ♪
♪ It's the pickle juice
challenge ♪
-All right, we both have
a jar -- I wish --
I almost wish that theme song
went on for like 25 minutes.
-I know.
It's cool that song already
existed and it you licensed it.
-That cost us $3 million.
-That's a -- I've always heard
that song's impossible to clear.
That and "Purple Rain."
-That and Led Zeppelin. Exactly.
All right, so we both have a jar
of pickle juice.
We have shot glasses,
and a set of pickle-related
trivia questions for each other.
If you get a question right,
you get a point.
If you get it wrong, you have
to take a shot of pickle juice.
Sound good?
-Yeah, this has been sitting
in my car all morning.
I wish I had brought it in.
-You should have put it
with the clay!
You should have put it
-It is hot pickle juice.
-Oh, my God. That's a totally
different game.
-Exactly.
-All right. Here we go.
I will ask the first question.
I'm gonna pour it
just in case I lose.
[ Inhales sharply ]
I can smell it already.
-It's pickly.
-Okay, here we go.
This first question is,
"Berrien Springs, Michigan,
is home to a yearly
pickle parade
led by a person who throws
pickles into the crowd
who goes by what title?
A, General Cucumber,
B, The Grand Dillmeister,
C, Sir Gherkin?
This question is for you.
-Wow. Um, I'm gonna say
The Grand Dillmeister.
[ Ding! ]
-That is correct!
-Yeah, baby!
-It is The Grand Dillmeister.
-Nice! Good.
-I was gonna say
General Cucumber.
Here we go. I got to do my shot
of pickle juice right here.
Cheers to you. Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Ah, ooh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Puts a little hair on the chest
there. Okay, here we go.
Very good.
All right, here we go.
Seth, now you ask me a question.
I'll see if I can
get this right.
-Okay, in Texas, it is common
to eat pickles where?
In a barbershop, in a voting
booth, or in a movie theater?
-[ Chuckles ]
-Where are Texans
unconventionally eating
their pickles?
-I'm gonna say not
a voting booth.
-That'd be weird.
-I would say, barbershop,
there's too much risk of hair.
-Hair on pickle contamination.
-I'm gonna say, clearly, movie
theater is my final answer.
[ Ding! ]
-Movie theater is right.
That means I drink
the pickle juice.
-Yeah, there you go. Congrats.
Oh, pinky up. I love that.
-Eww.
-It's good.
-I have not eaten today.
That's the first thing
I've put in my body today.
So that's weird.
-It's kind of like
kombucha, I guess.
-Yeah, I guess so.
It's fermented.
-Here we go. Made famous by a
viral video craze from 2015,
cats are known to do what
when they see a cucumber
on the floor?
A, cuddle it, B, get scared,
C, suddenly fall asleep.
-Whoa. I am not a cat person,
but this is great information,
whatever it is.
I'm gonna say get scared.
[ Ding! ]
Are they scared of cucumbers?
-Dude, this is unbelievable.
We got to take this on the road.
Are they still making
"Jeopardy!" episodes?
Me and you should team up.
That's good stuff.
All right, cheers to you.
It's gross.
You know, I've had picklebacks
before,
and that tastes different
because you kinda
can't taste it.
-It's one of the only things
that alcohol makes it taste
better.
-Gosh.
Okay, eww.
-One more question. Okay.
Southerners are known
for a regional snack
where they dip pickles in what?
A, Cool Ranch Doritos,
B, Kool-Aid, C, Cool Whip.
-I'm not sure if there's
actual dairy in Cool Whip,
but I'm sure if there is,
it would curdle or something.
-Yeah, you don't want to
dip your pickle in it.
"You don't want to
dip your pickle in it"
was one of your first movies.
-Yes, exactly.
It sounds like a movie
I would have made.
-Uh, I'm gonna say,
uh, weirdly enough,
I'm gonna -- This is bizarre
if I get this correct.
But Questlove once told me
about some weird thing.
I'm gonna say Kool-Aid.
-Yes! It's true!
I drink the pickle juice.
-That's bizarre.
How did I know that?
Okay, here we go.
This final round is worth
1,000 points, okay?
-Oh, good.
-All right. Here we go.
Oh, there's no question here.
-No.
Whoever can down the rest of
their pickle juice first wins.
Is that correct?
-[ Snickering ]
-Uh, I'm ready to just
call it a tie.
-I think a tie is good.
I've never been that
competitive, honestly.
I don't need to win in order
to have self-worth here.
-Yeah, me neither, buddy.
Friends forever, cheers.
I'll do one last shot with you.
You're awesome, buddy.
"An American Pickle" premieres
August 6th on HBO Max.
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show," everybody.